two families brought together by tragedy
are now working to turn their pain into
a platform for change the federal
government estimates that some 300
children between the ages of five are
younger died in swimming pool accidents
every year it's something two families
one time strangers endured on the same
day back in June Emme was a 19 month old
daughter of Olympic gold medal ski racer
bode miller and his wife Morgan and Levi
was Nicole Hughes energetic
three-year-old son CBS this morning
Saturday co-host Dana Jacobson joins us
with a family's new mission Dana good
morning good morning it really is a
tragic story it's resonating though with
so many people right now the lives of
both the Miller and Hughes families were
shattered by similar drowning accidents
and swimming pools
two months later those families are
working to sound the alarm to create
awareness of how fast and how often a
drowning occurs in hopes of preventing
other families from feeling the
devastation they now endure Cody Miller
has spent most of his life on the slopes
but today he's in the water with his
three year old son Nash as he learns to
kick then float rest and breathe pbbt
Miller and his wife Morgan chose this
self rescue course after their 19 month
old daughter Emmy made her way into a
neighbor's pool and drowned every time I
close my eyes I tried to go to sleep
replays in my head but it it happens so
fast and under normal everyday
circumstances of where life happens the
way it has for years and it's forever
changed our lives a new plan of action
is taking shape in the Millers home
where they're joining forces with water
safety advocates to create a wave of
change
we're in the early stages of development
and both the software and the hardware
knowing there's no one solution to
prevent drowning the group met with a
start-up using artificial intelligence
to monitor pools we can raise a lot of
awareness and things like that but we
want to have impact in the long run and
we want to make sure that the action
steps are you know can be accomplished I
can tell you from experience that a
three-year-old who has not had swim
lessons dreads Nicole Hughes lost her
son Levi when he drowned the same day as
Emmy both children always wore flotation
devices when swimming and were
supervised by parents but just like Emmy
Levi had been inside with his mom when
he slipped out unseen in seconds he was
gone there's no way around this he
depended on me to keep him safe and I
did not we weren't even swimming and
that to me has been what has more than
anything has continued to feel me and I
know that sounds so crazy but there is
just such a disconnect between people
think drowning is and what it really is
both Nicole and Morgan had to pull their
babies from the water both are mothers
two other children
their shared heartache is the basis for
their friendship and inspiration for
their fight I think one of the most
powerful things out there is a parent's
love for their children
to lose a child and still have that love
it needs to be directed somewhere to try
and reach the biggest audience they'll
soon meet with the AAP the American
Academy of Pediatrics parents need a
water safety plan I mean you know if a
pediatrician were to say what is your
water safety plan they hope to convince
the AAP to mandate that all
pediatricians discuss the dangers
surrounding water at regular check-ups
oh my gosh oh my gosh it's amazing
nash's the same age as Levi when he lost
his life
aside from birth defects drowning is the
leading cause of death in children ages
1 to 4 Nicole remembers Levi's last
visit to the doctor we discussed if he
could drink out of a cup if he could
scribble with a crayon lots of talk
about screen time and so can we please
talk about what really matters and that
is the well-being of my child and that
keeping him alive as a father even
before Emmy was born Bodi says he also
wishes their doctors had talked about
this silent killer it sounds like what
both of you are saying in some ways that
you want parents to be given this
information with the same sense of
urgency as they are given information
about SIDS about car seats vaccinations
this is the number one cause of death
for children under 4 you know and and
that to me should dominate the whole
conversation I think people look at you
and just wonder how do you get through
the day at this point in the service
when you talk about it with such love I
think that's one of the things that a
lot of people don't understand yes it
hurts and it's hard but she's still my
favorite topic of conversation I love
talking about her you know talking about
kids doesn't get old as a parent which i
think is the reason why we all only hang
out with others as the most decorated
male ski racer in the United States
Bode Miller knows his name recognition
is providing a platform that could help
their mission to permanently reduce the
number of deaths the Miller family is
working to find a new normal one that
includes a new baby boy
arriving in October one of the things
that we've wrestled with I've wrestled
with is the guilt and the responsibility
of it and how I need to change the way I
parent with this new understanding I
have four water and that's just gonna
take some time and patience with myself
now it goes without saying that swimming
pools can have a powerful pull on small
children both Emmie and Levi drowned
when they have been inside a home and
not expected to be near the pool a year
from now Morgan and Bodhi are hoping the
danger surrounding water is a topic that
every pediatrician is having with
parents and children are actually
learning about it in schools and that's
probably the biggest part of their
message we have to talk about this no
matter how uncomfortable it is they
can't bring their kids back and the coal
can't bring her son
they can't bring Emmy back but if they
can help save even one life that's why
it's so generous and brave of them to
share their pain with us in hopes that
it will help others and it will because
I think most people don't know the
statistic about drowning with little
kids you don't really know that
statistic until it happens to you
exactly that's why it's so great that
they're saying pediatricians please let
parents know Nicole said parents look
for the loophole I'm not going to be
that family and these are examples of
people that they are now that stand
parents have to listen that's the thing
if they Morgan said there's no more love
than a parent has for a child it was
true Dana thank you